How did you like the keynote?
It was
it was very interesting.
So I've never seen
Professor Hinton before.
it was raised
the discussion
and it's discussion
that's important
for sort of
the field to have.
There are a lot of words
that have different meanings
between apparently
different camps,
a lot of them
that have strong feelings
about their meaning
that’s
specific to
towards the first
part of his talk
when he was talking about
do LLMs understand really
given the definition
of understanding
that he was sort of outlining
that it's not complete,
it's just a spectrum
and then
might understand some things,
but they don't understand
a lot of things.
But I haven't really
looked into the philosophy
of both sides,
but
and then the other
side is like,
I've never really heard
very much
about analog computing.
That's the second part.
talking about models and AI,
and then it became agents.
So I'm very interested in
how LLMs are paving the way
for these LLM backed agents.
And I don't know if that's
the sense of the term
that he was using
the word agent in,
but the idea is of, yeah,
distillation and weight
sharing as as mechanisms
to make
these improve faster is
is another
interesting takeaway
for me from from the keynote.